devant disputer aujourd'hui on se trouve
non pas sur un jeu on se trouve pas ce
que j'ai envie de vous parler de vous
dire un petit peu quelques trucs en fait
ça fait quelques temps comme au mans sur
une vidéo je me dis [ __ ] est ce qu'il
y ait rien qui va choquer les gens dont
la vidéo est ce que c'est politiquement
correct est ce que tout ça et je veux
pas fonctionné comme ça je vais donc
vous parler de trois trucs que j'ai un
petit peu sur le moral en ce moment et
on va commencer par les jeux outils
mettre en situation des filles vous
savez déjà où je veux en venir et je la
poney a en gros le personnage est sorti
une compilation de jeux sur trois jeux
japonais dont un où tu vas dans le bain
d'une inconnue puis culmine gif et png
gif puis sa part en bas tf1 c'est
n'importe quoi et régulièrement quand je
fais ce genre de jeu je vois en
commentaire mondiale a beaucoup plus de
j'aime pas parce que ya peu il ya plein
de gens qui sont choqués et cm et une
partie de ces gens choqués laissent des
commentaires en mode à mais c'est
terrible ce que tu fais à personne soit
en compte de la situation a si justement
se rencontrent c'est un jeu vidéo en
plus très souvent mal faits qui met en
place une situation grotesque et absurde
et c'est ça qui nous fait rire en fait
c'est pas le fait qu'une fille se fasse
taper ça ça fait juste rien les
psychopathes
on parle donc d'un jeu vidéo souvent
japonais parce qu'ils arrivent justement
à faire cette distinction entre la vraie
vie et le dr chelou dans un jeu vidéo de
toutes les personnes qui sont choqués
par ces jeux vidéo a sachez que en rien
déjà j'approuve le comportement que des
hommes on dans ces jeux là haut rien je
je veux que les gens fassent ça dans la
vraie vie et aurélien je trouve ça
marrant soit ce qui est drôle comme je
le disais c'est le la grossièreté c'est
complètement débile
et c'est ça qui nous fait marrer c'est
pas le fait de gifle et une fille
gratuitement c'est des jeux vidéo si je
joue à gta 5 que je fais n'importe quoi
je crache un hélico sur un commissariat
ça fait 22 morts
je défonce une grand mère je vole son
sac à main bla bla bla bla dit comme ça
c'est totalement brutale et abusé mais
c'est un jeu vidéo et ça veut pas dire
que dans la vraie vie les gens vont
faire pareil et c'est pas dire que les
gens vont approuver ces comportements là
dans la vraie vie passe même pas ça veut
pas dire c'est sûr qu'au discours il est
pas parfait je le sais vous pouvez
attaquer sur plein de points mais c'est
juste que voilà ça me paraît évident que
j'approuve pas ces comportements et je
suis pas un vieux sexistes claqué
deuxième point qui a rejoint le premier
on reproche souvent fait un contenu pas
adaptés voire même choquant pour les
enfants je suis entièrement d'accord
le fait est que le nombre d'enfants sur
internet et sur facebook ces dernières
années a considérablement augmenté et
que les parents ne font pas du tout
attention à ce que leurs enfants
regardent quand la télé passe des séries
super violentes après 23 heures les
parents font attention à ce que leurs
enfants regardent et sur internet en
fait il devrait se passer la même chose
c'est pas aux créateurs de contenu de
s'autocensurer en prévision des futurs
enfants qui pourront tomber sur les
vidéos est là certains me diront ouais
mais tu pourrais quand même mettre ta
vidéo en moins 18 ans ou m - 18 dans le
titre et non parce qu'en fait quand à
plus de 13 ans tu peux regarder la vidéo
sans être choqué ou quoi donc pas besoin
de l'interdire à tous ceux qui ont moins
de 18 ans par contre je peux pas
dire à ceux qui ont uniquement moins de
13 ans c'est pas possible et en plus sur
youtube c'est comme facebook
il faut avoir 13 ans ou plus à la base
pour utiliser ces deux sites web alors
bon c'est très galère d'être totalement
dans le néant ce que je vous comprends
si j'avais 10 ans à l'heure actuelle
j'adorerais aller sur internet mais du
coup c'est la responsabilité des parents
de faire attention à ce que leur enfant
au regard des jeunes exemple concret là
dessus qu'ils m'avaient où j'ai pris
mesure d'un petit peu de l'impact que ça
là les parents qui finalement délaissent
un petit peu la responsabilité par
rapport à internet
j'ai un petit neveu qui a 7 ans elle
avait un poil est venu me voir et à noël
il me dit ouais à ta vidéo sur limite
limite c'était trop drôle plein de gros
mots est tous super
super et puis je suis allé voir sa mère
et je me suis aperçu qu'en fait elle en
avait rien à [ __ ] de ce que son enfant
faisait sur un mais pas que sur youtube
aller vite sur youtube va pas être
choqué il va juste entendu d'insulté les
blagues de cul ouais mais il ya bien
pire que ça sur internet
et ouais je pense que les parents
devraient contrôler un minimum ce que
leurs enfants font voilà je suis désolé
si vous avez du temps de regarder cette
vidéo et que votre papa était en train
de s'approcher d'eux devant le pc pour
mettre un contrôle parental enfin bref
voilà tout ça pour dire que je vais pas
me mettre à faire le casimir de youtube
parce que des enfants traînent sur
youtube c'est pas comme ça que ça doit
marcher donc je veux plus jamais en
temps on a un [ __ ] squeeze à des
enfants qui regardent des vidéos c'est
abusé ce que tu fais oui oui oui
troisième point qui n'a rien à voir avec
les deux premiers c'est le sentiment de
nostalgie les gens qui disent que j'ai
changé les gens qui disent que mes
vidéos c'était mieux avant que
maintenant je les travaille beaucoup
moins qu'avant parce qu'elles sont
beaucoup plus courte
bah c'est faux je comprends tout à fait
votre sentiment mais en fait je vous
expliquais alors déjà au niveau de la
durée des vidéos une vidéo de 3 minutes
peut être bien pu travailler qu'une
vidéo d'une heure tout simplement parce
qu'on a fait une heure d'enregistrement
qu'on a monté et qui ont donné trois
minutes au final et dans l'autre cas on
a fait une heure d'enregistrement qui
ont donné une heure de vidéo pas s'il
n'y a pas eu beaucoup de montage mais
dans les deux cas ça donne des bonnes
vidéos mais moi je préfère faire un truc
où je travaille énormément le montage et
qui donne une vidéo d' entre 4 et 8
minutes qui va super vite qu'à un bon
rythme avec vraiment les meilleurs
moments parce que moi-même quand j'ai
joué le reste m'a fait chier donc j'ai
pas envie de vous monter gilles m'a fait
chier tu vas aller droit au but et faire
une vidéo qui qu'à une petite histoire
courte et mouvementée c'est beau ce que
je dis [ __ ]
enfin bref je reviens là dessus il ya
plein de gens ça qu'ils le savent déjà
le deuxième point c'est les gens wiki
qui trouvent que le contenu a changé et
qui trouve que c'est plus comme avant
que c'est moins naturel et tout ça alors
c'est au aussi naturel qu'avant voire
même maintenant j'apprécie plus que
jamais de faire des vidéos puisque je
fais absolument ce que je veux en fait
je me faire plaisir avant tout parce que
même mon essence c'est ça c'est le
plaisir et si je me fais par exemple à
faire ce que les gens veulent et souvent
ce que les gens veulent c'est des trucs
du passé ben j'aurais moins de plaisir
et bah du coup mon réservoir il sera
vite parce que ouais j'suis une coquille
vide qu'on va faire en train de faire
mille d'eau et moi ce que je veux c'est
qui fait m'amuser et je pense que ça se
voit à l'image c'est ma façon de penser
par exemple en ce moment on voulait tous
que je refasse des quetsches sonntag son
des vidéos que j'en ai pas fait un
depuis plus d'un an alors ouais c'était
une superbe époque on a adoré les faire
avec mikhaïl sélectionner les questions
avec moi il tourne avec moi c'était
vraiment trop marrant mais le fait est
qu'au bout de 13 12 13 épisodes je crois
qu'on s'est un peu lassé on a pris moins
de plaisir et on n'est pas dans cette
politique de faire des vidéos qui
marchent vers des vidéos parce qu'on
sait que ça va marcher
on n'est plus dans cette politique de
faire des vidéos
parce que nous on va kiffer parce que
nous ça va nous faire marcher ça va nous
faire vraiment marrer et en l'occurrence
quelques chiens times si on en refait
ben ça va pas trop nous faire kiffer en
fait on s'est pas mal passé on avait
créé des persos vous avez tous envie de
revoir parce que vous les aviez trouvé
super marrant et je peux tout à fait le
comprendre mais moi des fois quand je
revois le coach d'ehg un petit peu
nostalgique mais je me dis bon bah voilà
c'était une bonne époque
maintenant c'est une nouvelle époque une
autre époque et puis on va recréer des
choses qui sont cools qui vont plaire
aux gens et beaucoup géant tandis que
j'ai changé et c'est vrai j'ai changé
mais en fait c'est juste que j'évolue en
plus je vieillis et puis voilà en
sortant kadéos par semaine on se
renouvelle aussi un peu on fait des
ondes
on explore des pistes ont fait des
nouveaux trucs parfois plus mature
parfois pas du tout mais là où
changement serait inquiétant si je
commence à moto censuré parce que ouais
mais vidéo deviennent virale touche de
plus en plus de gens à la chaîne youtube
a explosé et j'ai pas envie de changer
le contenu des vidéos pour l'adapter à
certains types de personnes ça ça me
ferait pas du tout qui fait et je trouve
même ça un peu grave en fait de parce qu
on atteint un certain niveau sur youtube
on doit plus vraiment être nous mêmes et
se retenir pas faire certaines choses
non je rigole mieux vaut rire que
pleurer mais ma vieille phrase mais
voilà c'est des trucs que je voyais
souvent revenir et je voulais
m'expliquer un petit peu avec vous parce
que finalement on fait quatre vidéos par
semaine mais on parle pas souvent comme
ça et pour toutes les femmes qui sentent
offensés devant les vidéos de jeux
japonais vraiment je m'excuse vraiment
si ça vous enfants sachez que je fais
pas du tout l'apologie de tout ce qui
peut se passer de dégueulasse dans la
vraie vie et a vraiment des gros fils de
[ __ ] sur cette planète et ça vous le
savez mieux que moi je n'en fais pas
partie et les gens qui regardent les
vidéos n'en font pas partie normalement
encore une fois on parla de jeux vidéo
de vidéos humoristiques devant lesquels
vous êtes censés passer un bon moment il
n'y a pas de message politique n'y a pas
de message quelconque ont fait aucune
apologie voilà réponse au hainaut vous
critiquez pas sinon c'est pas ça qu'on
vient de faire un pas du tout je voulais
juste vous parlez un peu voilà et bien
écoutez vers ça me regarde et j'espère
que vous passez un bon [ __ ] de samedi
j'avais rien à dire je trouve que cette
phrase on sentait une prochaine vidéo
merci d'avoir regardé surtout merci de
m'avoir écouté soyez rassurés plein de
bonnes choses pour vous et puis à 13
dans une prochaine vidéo portez vous
bien sûr tout le monde
pis